Simplify 4a squared b
and this whole quantity
is being raised to
the third power.
Now here, we'll just
use the property.
If we have the
product of things--
so let's say I have a times
b-- and I'm raising that
to some power n,
this is just going
to be equal to a to
the n times b to the n.
And to realize why
that happens, let's
just try it out with
a simple example.
If I have a times b
to the third power,
what is that going
to be equal to?
That is going to be
equal to a times b--
that to the first power--
then times a times b--
that's to the second
power-- times a times b--
that's to the third power.
That's exactly what--
we're literally
taking this expression and
multiplying by itself three
times.
Now, we can just swap
these around because
of the commutative and
the associative properties
of multiplication.
So if we just swap
these around, just
change the order that
we're multiplying,
we can rewrite this as a
times a times a times b times
b times b.
We have three a's
here, three b's.
And so this over here is
going to be a to the third,
and this right
over here is going
to be equal to b to third.
So we have a to the third
times b to the third.
So it worked, and
so hopefully that
gives you a sense of
why this property holds.
Now, let's apply it
to the actual problem.
So we have 4a squared
b to the third power.
That means that each of these
components in the product
are going to be raised
to the third power.
So that means it equals
4 to the third power
times a squared to
the third power times
b to the third power.
Let me color code it.
This third power
here in magenta,
that's this third
power over here.
I'm just raising-- instead
of taking the product first
and then raising that
to the third power,
I can take each of the
terms in the product, each
of the numbers in the
product, and raise those
to the third power first
and then take the product.
So that's what we're doing.
And let's try to simplify this.
So what is 4 to the third power?
4 to the first is 4,
4 to the second is 16,
and then we want to
multiply 16 times 4.
So 4 to the third power, which
is 4 times 4 times 4, is 64.
And then we have
a squared, and we
are raising that
to the third power.
Well, we know from
the product property
of exponents, that's going to
be a to the 2 times 3 power,
or a to the sixth power.
So this is a to the sixth power.
We got 6 from 2 times 3.
And then finally, we just
have the b to the third power.
Let me do that in
a different color.
We just have the b
to the third power,
and we'll just
write it over here.
So we simplify this
expression to 64 a
to the sixth b to
the third power.